Continuing
with the remainder part of the 20th
narration of
authored by Noi, the narration of
in the chapter of repentance
regarding the man who had murdered 100
souls and and sought redemption.
We left off at the advice of the scholar
that he went to.
And this scholar as we mentioned
did not just provide an answer and a
solution but he provided a blueprint
for this
man
to be able to repent.
It's very easy and anybody can say this
is wrong, this is right and
to complain about that which is
wrong. However, to replace it, to have a
plan
that is both practical and reasonable in
order to
lessen this evil or eradicate it, this
is the domain of the scholarship of
Islam.
And so
he said to him,
Go to such and such land. There are
people there who are worshiping Allah.
Be with them and worship Allah with them
and amongst them. And do not come back
to your land
here
because it is an evil place. How does he
know it's an evil place? How do we know
it's an evil place? What are the
indicators? Well, we've got a man that's
killed a hundred souls.
A serial mass murderer
who has killed a hundred people and he's
not in prison. He's walking around free.
Free as a bird. This would articulate a
very terrible place. A place where
oppression is rampant and there are very
little consequences, if any.
[Silence]
Why is it that he killed 100 people?
It's possible that he was an executioner
even for the official parties that were
in charge. The point is is that it is an
evil place. And it is almost impossible,
not impossible, almost impossible to be
good in a bad place. And
a person who is in a bad place
must leave that place in order to
leave the actions that that place
brought out of him and the bad habits
that that place brought out of him.
And so
and so he left for this land of
righteous people. And when he reached
the exact middle of his way, the exact
middle point between the two places,
the angel of death came to say take
his soul and death came for him.
And then both the angels of mercy and
the angels of punishment began to debate
with one another and argue as to who is
more rightful to take this man's soul.
We understand from this narration and
others
that
the angel of death
is what ultimately comes and takes the
person's soul from his or her body
at the very end. However, there are
angels of death.
Angels of death that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has mentioned.
So
these messengers that Allah mentions in
the Quran, they are the angels of death.
The angels of death, they are either
angels of mercy or angels of punishment
and torment. They come and they prepare
the soul to be extracted from the body
and they stand around the person as far
as the eye can see. As the prophet
mentions in the narration of
that as far as he can see and everywhere
he looks he sees angels of death. They
are either angels of punishment or
angels of mercy. When finally the angel
of death comes at the exact moment when
this person was written to pass and
extracts this person's soul and gives it
to either the angels of torment or the
angels of reward and pleasure. And so
these angels began to debate with one
another as to who is more rightful to
this person. And we will finish this
[Arabic recitation]